yo soy actualmente el director del grupo
espectáculo los abuelos de chile
somos un grupo de viejo
que lo pasamos como decimos en chile
chancho lo pasamos bien cantando
bailando y hemos traspasado eso a los
nuestros
entonces yo vengo acá para decirles a
ustedes que es ser adulto mayor a ser
adulto mayor es hacer hacer cosas no
quedar en escondido ahí en el planeta
marte metiendo esto en un hoyo sino que
todos los días
saludarnos
en el espejo por ejemplo yo lo hago
hola rodolfo buenos días que tengas el
mejor día de tu día y chau y después voy
hago lo que tengo que hacer en el baño
pero lo primero que parto yo hice lo que
digo ustedes hagan lo partan con ustedes
deseen se ustedes la felicidad y después
una cosa que yo siempre enseñe el nido
de águila chiquillo ponchó a dos
después me lo comió nike ya estuve me
entiendes tú pero es eso si tú quieres
tratar no algo bien o mal y después será
mejor pero hazlo recuerden es observa
bien dime qué es ahí mira para acá
menos lindo ya pero se ríe no es cierto
pero este chiquillo es tu futuro vas a
ser adulto mayor sí o sí ahora si
quieres llegar como llovía o si queréis
llegar así yo tengo 79 años
cuídate
no sea el logo cuídate es tu cuerpo ok
eso es un mensaje
este es tu futuro serás adulto mayor lo
será como quieres llegar entonces
chiquillo cómo quieres llegar cuando se
haya adulto mayor
tienes que ahora planificar así como
estaba diciendo en las charlas
anteriores
tienes que planificar sin pero vas a ser
adulto mayor
quieres tener una carrera como decía
delante cross y él da dinero todo eso y
con eso por ese motivo tú vas es lo que
yo hablaba con él delante tú vas
escondiendo sus potencialidades porque
necesitas otras cosas y cuando es el
tiempo para ustedes sacar la
potencialidad que tienen cuando sean
adultos mayores
y ahí es y eso es lo que yo he
descubierto en este momento entonces
para que tú seas un adulto mayor feliz
que puedas ayudar al planeta todo esto
todo depende de ti de nadie más eres tú
es tu vida y tú tienes que tomar la
decisión
qué es hacer adulto mayor la sociedad te
dice es un número por ley si el hombre
cumple 65 años de adulto mayor y
deniegue retirarse lobo
la mujer a los 60 tiene entonces es un
número ser adulto mayor
piénsenlo no les voy a dar la respuesta
después la sociedad te dice fíjate que
yo te lo lo experimento va tranquilo te
quita no moleste quiere seguir en el
rinconcito no moleste
eso es lo que se siente cuando uno es
adulto mayor después
es ser invisible
jóvenes ustedes tienen adultos mayores
en su familia
piensen en eso no los invisibilizan no
los invisibilizan a mí me ha tocado de
repente que me dice un joven un beso que
hay perdón no lo vi soy invisible
ekkachai ahora me empecé a preocupar
cuando empezaron a dar el asiento en el
metro a esté llegando a viejo viejo
estoy llegando a viejo y que ser viejo
usted a los profesores le dicen ah sí
puse el viejo que molestaba sí o no y no
es esa la realidad
no molestamos y tú cómo quieres ser de
adulto mayor y qué harás para ello las
naciones unidas- tú sabes te dicen esto
las famosas 3 p potenciar el retorno al
respeto la consideración y la autoridad
de los adultos mayores yo no no no estoy
muy de acuerdo o sea si tenemos que
potenciar no a nosotros como adultos
mayores pero el respeto lo ganamos
nosotros nosotros no ganamos el respeto
siendo haciendo y mostrando
amando siendo felices eso es potencial
después ustedes tienen que promover la
participación del adulto mayor en la
vida económica y social
en eso es la gran tarea que tiene
ustedes los jóvenes para dónde van a los
adultos mayores no es no no es
productivo este compadre no es
productivo no se puede mover que ha
dormido en el trabajo ya no es mentira
somos pro somos productos y podemos
producir eso es lo que dice ay ok
después hablamos de potenciar la vida
independiente con pleno funcionamiento
físico y psicológico qué significa eso
esto la oportunidad que me dio
andrew y abigail y ustedes al invitarme
a comentar con usted
viejo
porque la gente le tiene miedo a la
palabra viejísimo y no compadre las
cosas se van poniendo vieja ahora tú la
puede remozar la puedes pintar la puedes
poner bonita la puedes usar de otra
manera y así es como se tiene que
trabajar el potenciar la vida
independiente con el funcionamiento
físico ustedes van a ver más adelante
lo que yo estoy predicando en estos
momentos y con el gobierno esto es
luchando con el gobierno pasado también
luche para que para que nos den una
oportunidad a que nosotros llevemos
nuestra felicidad a los nuestros y a los
jóvenes la felicidad de que de vivir con
nuestras potencialidades ahora nuestra
potencialidad es cantar
y bailar
y eso es lo que llevamos a los adultos
mayores pero nos llevamos solamente la
canción
antigua donde ayer justamente estaba
estaba yo cantando en un hogar por allá
por vivaceta le cantábamos a una señora
en sillas de ruedas
durmiendo sé pero les decía yo les digo
a ellas
en este momento saben lo que es disco
duro algunas aves se los tengo que
explicar es una cosita que hay dentro de
los como sean secciones de los peces
y está todo ahí y ustedes también
nosotros los adultos mayores y ellos
tenemos acá la el disco duro lo que pasa
es que no lo usamos entonces qué hacemos
les cantamos un bolero bésame bésame
mucho y ellos buscan la la letra y
empiezan a ejercitar su potencialidad
chiquillo eso es lo que actualmente
nosotros
en mi grupo está haciendo y es lo que yo
decidí en el año 2010 crear esta que se
llama ya sea la propia ciudad el tiro a
vuelo terapia porque es una terapia para
los adultos mayores y que lo hace
felices a ustedes por ejemplo si yo
tuviera mi grupo aquí nosotros les
cantaría mos ustedes saben cuál de luis
fonsi
de paz
y como lo hacemos se pone una vieja allí
del grupo a 62 y tengo yo y digo
abuelita despacito despacito y ella se
empieza para que haya que despacito
mirándote tengo que bailar contigo hoy
te fijas entonces es eso la vida de
aprender nosotros de luis fonsi de
carlos vive lo actualidad y llevarlo y
saber con qué gozan ustedes y ahí va la
próxima
prevenir la enfermedad es bueno yo ya
tengo mi punto de vista acerca de
prevenir las enfermedades prevenir las
enfermedades no en médicos
viste un médico y que el examen no es
hoy una manera muy particular mía de
pensar yo no entro ni a las farmacias
compay a ese cuando ando siempre los
entró a preguntar la hora a lo mejor
técnicas pero eso es una cosa personal
de cada uno por qué porque me he cuidado
yo en mi alimentación de realmente
hablaban de la de la alimentación y eso
es importante
sería otra charla acerca de eso porque
yo me he mantenido de esta manera yo no
uso agua caliente por ejemplo yo me daño
con agua helada comadre invierno y
verano se ducha claro que no hay que
tirarse hay que saber cómo tirarse el
agua helada pues acá otra charla
bien velar por el bienestar físico
mental social espiritual y ambiental por
supuesto
entonces la organización de las naciones
unidas les dice a ustedes queridos y
amigos jóvenes esto es lo que tienen que
hacer ustedes no lo a nosotros nosotros
ya estamos hechos ustedes tienen que
potenciar todos estos aspectos de su
vida y sobre todo como decía mi amigo
crociere buscar la
ciudad
es lo primero como les decía a ustedes
felicidad sin la felicidad no vamos
ninguna va a ninguna parte
entonces debemos trabajar chiquillo y
eso es lo que yo les digo las
universidades cuando hoy
a trabajar con alumnos docentes al que
quieras qué hago yo hay en terapia
ocupacional con ellos es esto mismo es
el puente que debemos poner nosotros es
el puente generacional nosotros como
adultos mayores y ustedes como jóvenes
juntarnos que haya una comunicación y
acuérdense que los puentes este es para
de doble tráfico
tanto nosotros los adultos mayores
podemos acudir a donde están ustedes y
ustedes acercarse a nosotros donde
estamos los adultos mayores y los
necesitamos chiquillos no podemos vivir
el uno sin el otro
yo le digo a los viejos no nos olvidemos
de los jóvenes que andan con la cuestión
aquí y mire
no importa aprendamos a vivir y tenemos
que aprender los whatsapp los apps y
todo eso y nos juntamos pero ustedes
también tienen que saber lo que nos
gusta a nosotros como adultos mayores no
es cierto y aquí cruzamos este famoso
puente
al que yo lo hice a propósito con esa
curva porque cuesta subirlos
cuesta subir el puente por ambos lados
pero tenemos que hacerlo por lo mejor y
para tu vida ahora
esto lo hicimos en arica
una maratón del adulto mayor en
noviembre del año pasado mire cómo
bailan todos
y nosotros estamos cantando el embrujo y
américo mira cómo bailan todos ellos ya
habían corrido la maratón de 5 km
jóvenes también todos los carabineros
ahí estamos nosotros ya arriba en el
escenario
[Música]
creo que bailar
los pasos de salsa se lo enseñamos
adelante atrás y a vivir porque américa
y se a morir no nunca acudir chiquillos
a vivir esa es la manera
[Música]
[Aplausos]
mejores
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y eso es lo que hacemos nosotros lo
abuelo llevamos esas terapias a todos y
me mira como esa gente después de haber
corrido
bueno nosotros habíamos estado en una
presentación anteriormente terminamos
este y después nos fuimos a otra
teníamos de tres presentaciones diarias
ya llevando todo lo nuestro a los
adultos mayores pero a lo que voy yo es
que ahora que ustedes me han escuchado
que han visto esto
digamos
y como quiero ser yo como adulto mayor
y como quiero ser yo para la sociedad
como adulto mayor que como quiero ser yo
para mi familia en el adulto mayor y lo
más importante es que quiero ser yo para
futuro como adulto mayor en mi vida
hoy muchas gracias muy amables
[Aplausos]